hello and welcome to this video playing
Grand Master's no kids I usually I have
a king's indian against him but okay if
i go e for that probably won't happen i
don't i don't know what is playing
against you for at all i think maybe i
might have tried it again Sicilian in
city six yeah i think i'll go d for him
see what he plays term on off there's a
wide range still to you six some things
we won't get no dragons but you six is
fairly flexible twins 27 okay i go with
a more strategic line i don't i don't
have huge knowledge there of the sharper
one so i'm okay with this the fianchetto
is pretty okay against this I think
white still has some chances to play for
for an edge h5 that's very early
okay hmm yeah i was thinking Bishop f4
here maybe then he has to go d 6 e 595 I
don't think he wants to wants to see yet
now if i take yesterday with the pawn I
was thinking then e5 King's Bishop takes
but he has d5 so I don't know how
dangerous this is I can go okay one for
potential 95 yes I think various ways
maybe to win a piece but it takes takes
if I for example then 95 Queen somewhere
could be eight I could clean b6 I don't
think he can afford that he has no
development here i rather expect him
look like okay this first and then it's
a move like Bishop takes actually what's
interesting huh should have thought
about that that a little bit a little
bit 95 m
so let's see him the thing is I have
some aggressive moves but I don't know
if they really threaten all that much
even the sacrifices of course come into
consideration like 95 but it doesn't
threaten all that much as I said but
it's difficult difficult to play a slow
movie actually i have already everything
developed taking is wrong a4a 59 f 1 i'd
be six would be a strategic idea ok I
can I can do that
ok so now I'm going to going to see what
what's what does that's too much
weakening the long diagonal so 95 is the
is the move to try and cannot really a
five I could insert a five maybe not
sure what it does ok let's go 95 yeah I
think he takes d5 is kind of mandatory
the idea now is to take and play d 6 I
expect him to Castle long I'm not sure
that that's feels feels relatively best
ideas be 45 just open it out
ok that's an interesting move and I
don't like to but I think you have to do
this going into looking at c-6 is not
bad
not easy to say maybe this is not a
correct sacrifice but I think for blitz
cam is it's okay okay take it or cc5
also makes sense Queen takes rook see
one context but should be five whoa so
we wants to suck the Queen okay that's
an idea definitely IDM okay so Jack take
this is also hanging that's probably the
reason why it isn't a good idea at least
objectively okay so okay some stuff
hanging what you go with the rook here I
would love to go to some active square
hmm
hmm cannot calculate that okay so i'm
playing in normal Bishop Jake's
sometimes actually materialize he's
actually a head which is pretty crazy
Jack didn't didn't really appreciate
that as I actually force a problem
it's roped his seven playable for him
probably probably
I rupee seven works d7 we can even ditch
the nightfall a check
you
maybe I have oh I didn't see that move
that's very unfortunate I simply didn't
see the check check check Jim check
check check check check check check oh I
didn't expect that one and I okay well
that was very very unclear stuff
probably winning for either side in some
cases okay so let's have a look they're
probably objectively I cannot sacrifice
but I mean he's playing so provocatively
in a blitz game you should really go all
night at five and no night d 5 i'm just
curious at the situation with this g5
take 65 yeah it does win what did i do
wrong I have to play Bishop b5 first and
then it's over mmm yeah I somebody's
just didn't see that he can actually
check the guy was just thinking okay I'm
winning here and that's it but i have to
take first and rook c1 and then it's
over now this is a much better version
of course of the game I'm just useless
just material up for nothing so that was
the thing I can't plate this quite
quickly add looks looks normal but this
is some
ok before still winning but here I lost
the thread so these six wins yeah I kind
of suspected that to be honest I was
thinking like that could win but I
couldn't figure it out I saw this Jack
and I quit I didn't see a continuation
here okay but isn't that its Queen f3
jack aah i didn't think about that I saw
this move just and then I thought King
c8 and I didn't see anything I didn't
see a continuation back we have three
wins check yeah once you see it it's not
is not that difficult ok so these six
was winning maybe I should have just
trusted my instincts down yeah things if
this check I take here so okay so i had
had tons of ways to to win the game ja
him of course chata his pieces now
prevail I Quincy 7 first is a draw hey
check it was stupid that I could have
seen ready it was was quite easy in
check now this is jank for him now check
china i can give tons of checks but not
it's not a real find anymore yeah it's a
bit of a shame against that opening you
should really win the game h5 is very
risky to be conservative down and I
don't know maybe I shouldn't cancel me
out something one thing is clear this is
better I saw that a little bit i saw
that too late this is better because it
gives me additional options now
something like night
can I can punish with therefore I think
they have a hard time to believe that
you can play like that with all the
pieces on the back rank alright it's not
easy to kill off it seems the engine
also doesn't see much it just gives us
an equal maybe still hard to believe and
the engine wants to defend with f6 I
mean did this for a human player this
looks like looks very dangerous but the
engine is very very cool about it yeah
okay now we even get some counter-attack
going yeah I'd say it's a whole mess em
I got some good winning position but
mostly because it's so difficult to play
for black yeah I kind of like this i
played this quite okay but here I've
really squandered all the advantage hmm
okay thanks guys